both of you or embark on your next
careers you know helping to change the
world I'm curious what the process is
when you decide what to focus on there's
so many many things there well when I
left the whiteouts I decided to focus on
things that I had cared about when I was
there where I could still make a
difference one is our Health Access
Initiative thanks largely to funding
from the Gates Foundation where we've
been able to drive down the price of
AIDS in malaria drugs in Melinda and I
always knew we'd have the responsibility
in the enjoyment of giving the resources
away so it was an exploration process
and really traveling throughout the
world when you see the poorest and you
see what we take for granted in terms of
our children surviving our children's
health that became the thing to go after
speaking of that I know you have
traveled together there you know so I'm
curious of a couple things one is
because both of you're so famous how do
you get past the bubble to really
connect with people there we go a lot of
places where people have no television
so we're not all that famous you just
have to go to these places and ask
questions when bill and I went Melinda
was with us tonight she asks better
questions than we did on some of these
hiv/aids prevention and efforts I was
very impressed whether there was a
microbe aside which is a thing a woman
can use to protect herself from getting
HIV and it was a trial and understanding
was it something that the woman's did
she was the experience so okay for her
and what about her partner neither bill
or I were willing to ask them in a very
direct way we were sort of hinting at it
but Melinda was able to ask very
directly both the male and female and
and it was good it's important feedback
and one of the things that I respected
about what Bill and Melinda were doing
it they were willing to work in the zoo
to listen to had when we were there the
third or fourth highest AIDS infection
rate in the world but it had the only
government at the time that was willing
to say look we're going to test
everybody twelve years old
unless they out there and we had gone
out our Health Access Group and found
people who were HIV positive who were
willing to go up into these villages a
third of the people live in the
mountains so high that you can't get
there except on pack animals or foot all
they knew was we were showing up trying
to help them you know I was just there
in the in Malawi at one of our farm
projects and the woman that we were
helping there was farming an acre with a
hoe and she was at learned new planting
techniques and she looked at me and she
said do you think you could do this got
a hoe and we were planning together
she said how'd you learn to do this and
I explained it when I was six I lived on
a little farm like this and you know
that's much more important that we can
help them live their lives than who we
used to be do you agree with that sir